All
right,
this is CS50.
This is week 3,
and this was an artist's rendition of what
various sorting algorithms look and sound like.
Recall from week 0 that an algorithm is just step
by step instructions for solving some problem to sort information,
as in the real world just means to order it
from like smallest to largest or alphabetically or some other heuristic.
And it's among the algorithms that we're going
to focus on today in addition to searching,
which of course is looking for.
Information as we did in week 02.
Among the goals for today are to give you
a sense of certain computer science building blocks like
there's a lot of canonical algorithms out there that
most anyone who studied computer science would know,
anyone who leads a tech interview would ask.
But more importantly,
the goal is to give you different mental models for and methodologies
for actually solving problems by giving you a sense of how these,
uh,
real world algorithms can be translated to actual computers.
You and I can control.
We thought we'd begin today with an actual algorithm
for sort of taking attendance.
We of course do this with scanners outside,
but we can do it old school whereby I just
use my hand or my mind and start doing 123456789,
1011,
12,
and so forth.
That's going to take quite a few steps because
I've got to point at and recite a number for
everyone in the room so I could kind of
do what my like grade school teachers taught me,
which is count by 2s,
which would seem to be faster.
So like 2468,
1012,
1416,
1820,
and clearly that sounds and is actually faster,
but I think with a little more
intuition and a little more thought back to week zero,
I dare say we could actually do much better than that.
So if you won't mind,
I'd like you to humor us by all standing up
in place
and think of the number one,
if you could,
and join us in this here algorithm.
So stand up
in place
and think of the number 1.
So at this point in the story,
everyone should be thinking of the number 1.
Step 2 of this algorithm for you is going to be this pair off with someone standing,
add their number to yours,
and remember the sum.
Go
OK.
At this point in the story,
everyone,
except maybe one lone person if we've got an odd number of people in the room,
is thinking of what number?
2,
OK,
so next step,
one of you
in each pair
should sit down.
OK.
Good.
Never seen some people sit down so fast.
So,
those of you who are still standing,
the algorithm's still going.
So the next step for those of you still standing is this,
if still standing,
go back to step
2.
Ergo repeat or loop if you could.
Um
And notice if you've gone back to step 2,
that leads you to step 3,
that leads some of you to step 4,
which leads you back to step 2.
So this is a loop.
Keep going.
If still standing,
pair off with someone else,
still standing,
add together,
and then one of you sit down.
So with each passing second,
more and more people should be sitting down.
And fewer and fewer are standing.
OK.
Almost everyone is sitting down.
You're getting farther and farther away from each other.
That's OK.
I can help with some of the math at the end here.
All right.
I see a few of you still standing,
so I'll help out and I'll I'll join you together.
So I see you in the middle here.
What's your number?
32.
OK,
go ahead and sit down and I'll pair you off with what's your number?
20.
OK,
you can go ahead and sit down.
Uh,
who's still
Then you're still standing.
27?
OK,
you can sit down.
You guys are still adding together,
who's gonna stay standing?
OK,
what's your number?
The worst part is doing like arithmetic across a crowded room,
but
27 also?
47.
OK,
you can sit down.
Is anyone still standing?
Yeah.
Nice,
15.
OK,
you can sit down.
Anyone still standing?
OK,
so all I've done is sort of automate the process of pairing people up at the end here.
When I hit enter,
we should hopefully see,
oh,
the numbers are a little,
what's going on there?
There we go.
When I hit enter,
we'll add together all of the numbers that were left.
And if you think about the algorithm that we just executed,
each of you started with the number 1 and then half of you handed off your number.
Then half of you handed off your number,
then half of you handed off your number.
So theoretically all of these ones with which we
started should be aggregated into the final count,
which if this room weren't so big,
would just be in one person's mind,
and they would have declared what the total number of people in the room is.
I'm going to speed that up by hitting enter on the keyboard,
and if your execution of this algorithm is correct,
there should be.
141 people in the room.
According to our old school human though,
Kelly,
who did this manually one at a time,
the total number of people
in the room,
according to Kelly,
if you want to come on up and
shouted into the microphone is of course going to be,
I don't know,
something around 160,
I think 160,
so not quite the same.
OK,
but that's pretty good.
round of applause for your,
your accuracy.
OK,
so ideally counting one at a time would have been perfectly correct.
So we're only off by a little bit.
Now,
presumably that's just because of some bugs in execution of the algorithm,
maybe some mental math didn't quite go according to plan,
but theoretically your third and final algorithm wherein you all participated,
should have been much faster than my algorithm or Kelly's algorithm,
whether or not we were counting one at a time or two at a time.
Why?
We'll think back to week zero when we did the whole phone book example,
which was especially fast in it.
Final form because we were dividing and conquering,
tearing half of the problem away,
half of the problem away.
And even though it's hard to see in a room like this,
it stands to reason that when all of you were standing up,
we took a big bite out of the first problem and half of you sat down,
half of you sat down,
and theoretically there would have been if you were closer in
space,
one single person with the final count.
So let's see if we can analyze this
just a little bit by considering We did.
So here's that same algorithm.
He recall is how we motivated Week zero's
demonstration of the phonebook in either digital form,
as you might see in an iPhone or Android device,
looking for someone,
for instance,
like John Harvard who might be at the beginning,
middle,
or end of said phonebook,
but we analyzed that algorithm just as we can now this one.
So in my very first verbalized algorithm,
1234,
you could draw that as a straight line because the relationship between the number
of people in the room and the of time it takes is linear.
It's a straight line with each additional person in the room.
It takes me one more step.
So if you think to sort of high school math,
there's sort of a slope of one there.
And so this N number denoting number of people in the room is indeed a straight line.
And on the x axis,
as in week 0,
we have the size of the problem in people and the time to
solve in steps or seconds or whatever your unit of measure is.
If and when I started counting 2 at a time,
2468,
10.
And so forth.
That still is a straight line because I'm taking two bytes consistently out of
the problem until maybe the very end where there's just 1 person left,
but it's still a straight line,
but it's strictly faster.
No matter the size of the problem,
if you sort of draw a line vertically,
you'll see that you hit the yellow line well before you
hit the red line because it's moving essentially twice as fast.
But that third and final algorithm,
even though in reality it felt like it took a while and I had to
kind of bring us to the exciting conclusion by doing some of the math.
That looked much more like our 3rd and final phone book
example because if you think about it from an opposite perspective,
suppose there were twice as many people in the room.
Well,
it would have taken you all theoretically just one more step.
You know,
granted one more loop and there might be some substeps in there if you will,
but it's really just fundamentally one more step.
If the number of people in the room quadrupled,
4 times as many people,
well,
that's 2 more steps.
equivalently,
the amount of time it takes to solve the Attendance problem using that 3rd and final
algorithm grows very slowly because it takes a huge number of more people in the room
before you even begin to feel the impacts of that
growth.
And so today indeed,
as we talk about not only the correctness of algorithms,
we're going to talk about the design of algorithms as well,
just as we have code because the smarter you are with your design,
the more efficient your algorithms ultimately are going to be and the slow.
Where their cost is going to grow and by cost I mean time like here maybe it's money,
maybe it's the amount of storage space that you need.
Any limited resource is something that we can ultimately measure,
and we're not going to do it very precisely.
Indeed,
we're going to use some broad strokes and some
standard mechanisms for describing ultimately the running time,
the amount of time it takes for an algorithm or in turn code to actually run.
So how can we do this?
Well,
last week we're called,
we set the stage.
for talking about something called arrays which were the simplest
of data structures inside of a computer where you just take
the memory in your computer and you break it up
into chunks and you can store a bunch of integers,
a bunch of strings,
whatever,
back to back to back to back,
and that's the key characteristic for an array.
It is a chunk of memory wherein all of the values they're in are back to back to back,
so right next to each other in memory.
So we drew this fairly abstractly by drawing a grid like this and I said,
Well,
maybe this is byte 0 and this is by.
1 billion,
whatever the total amount of memory is that you have,
we zoomed in and looked at a little something like this a canvas of memory.
We talked about what and where you can put things,
but today let's just assume that we want 1234567 chunks of memory for the moment,
and inside of them we might put something like these numbers here.
Well,
the interesting thing about computers is that even though if I were
to ask you all find the number 50 in this array,
I mean,
our eyes quickly.
See where it is because we sort of have this bird's eye
view of the whole screen and it's obvious where 50 is,
but the catch with computers and with code that we write
is that really these arrays,
these chunks of memory,
are equivalent to a whole bunch of closed doors and the computer
can't just have this bird's eye view of everything.
If the computer wants to see
what
value is at a certain location,
it has to do the metaphorical equivalent of going to that location,
opening the door,
and looking.
Then closing it and moving on to the next.
That is to say,
a computer can only look at or access one value at a time.
Now that's in the simplest form.
You can build fancier computers that theoretically can do more than that,
but all of the code we write generally is going to assume that model.
You can't just see everything at once.
You have to go to each location in these here lockers,
if you will.
Starting today too,
when we talk about the locations in memory,
we're going to use our old zero indexing vernacular.
That is to say we start counting from 0 instead of 1.
So this will be
locker 0,
locker 1,
locker 2,
all the way up to locker 6.
So just ingrained in your mind that if you hear something like location 6,
that's actually implying that there's at least 7
total locations because we started counting at 0.
So that's intentional.
We don't have in the real world yellow lockers,
so we're going to make this metaphor red instead.
We do have these lockers here and suppose that within these 7 lockers physically.
On stage
we've put a whole bunch of money,
monopoly money,
if you will,
but the goal initially here is going to be to search for
some specific denomination of interest and
use these physical lockers as a metaphor
for what your computer is going to do and what
your code ultimately is going to do if we're searching for
the solution to a problem like this.
The input to the problem at hand is 7 lockers,
all of whose doors are metaphorically closed,
the output of which we want to be a bull,
true or false answer.
Yes or no,
that number is there or no,
it is not.
So inside of this black box today is going to be the first of our algorithms,
step by step instructions for solving some problem where the
problem here is defined among all of these dollar bills,
specifically the $50 bill.
If we could get two volunteers to come on up who are ideally really good at monopoly.
OK,
how about over here in front and uh how about let me look a little farther and back.
over here,
there and back.
Come on down.
All right,
as these volunteers kindly come down to the stage,
we're going to ask them in turn to search for
specifically the $50 bill that we've hit in in advance.
And if my colleague Kelly could come on up too because we're going to do this twice,
once searching
in one with one algorithm and a second time with another.
Let me go ahead and say hello
if you'd like to introduce yourselves to the group.
Hey,
I'm Jose Garcia.
Hi,
I'm Caitlin Cow.
All right,
Jose and Caitlin,
nice to meet you both.
Come on over and let me go ahead and propose that Jose,
um,
the first algorithm that I'd like you to do is
to find the number 50 and let's keep it simple.
Just start from the left and work your way to the right.
And with each time you open the door,
stand over to the side so people can see what's inside and
just hold the dollar amount up for the world to see.
All right?
The floor is yours.
Find us the $50 bill.
No,
that's good.
That's good acting too.
Thank you.
No,
you can shut it
just like the computer,
all right.
No,
very clear,
thank you.
Mm,
still no $10 bill.
Next locker.
$5 bill,
not going well.
$100 bill,
but not the one we want.
This 1
$1 bill,
still no $50.
Of course,
you've been sort of set up to fail,
but here,
amazing,
a round of applause,
Jose found the $50 bill.
All right,
so let me ask you,
Jose,
you found the $50 bill.
Um,
it clearly took you a long time.
Just describe in your own words what was your algorithm,
even though I nudged you.
Yeah,
so my algorithm was basically walk up to the first door available,
open it,
check if the dollar bill was the dollar bill that I was looking for,
and then put it back and then go.
The next one.
OK,
so it's very reasonable because if the $50 bill were there,
Jose was absolutely going to find it eventually,
if slowly.
In the meantime,
Kelly's going to kindly reshuffle the numbers behind these doors here.
And even though Jose took a long time here,
I mean,
what if Jose like wouldn't have been smart to start from the other end instead,
do you think?
Um,
not necessarily because we don't know if the 50 is going to be at that end.
Exactly.
So he could have gotten lucky if he sort of
flaunted my advice and didn't start on the left,
but instead started on the right,
boom,
he would have solved this in one step.
But in general,
that's not really going to work out.
Maybe half the time it will,
you'll get lucky,
half the time it won't,
but that.
Not really a fundamental change in the algorithm whether you go left to right,
right to left,
to Jose's point,
if you don't know anything a priori about the numbers,
the best you can probably do
is just go through linearly left to right or right to left,
so long as you're consistent.
Now,
could you have jumped around randomly?
Uh,
I guess I could have,
but if again,
if they weren't in any like specified order,
I don't think it would have helped either.
Yeah,
so and additionally,
if he just jumped around to random order,
then you might get lucky and it might be in the very first one,
might have taken fewer steps ultimately,
but
presumably you're going to have to then keep track
of like which locker doors have you opened.
So that's going to take some memory or space.
Not a big deal with 7 lockers,
but if 70 lockers,
700 lockers,
even random probably isn't going to be the best job.
So let me go ahead and take the mic away and hand it over to Caitlin.
You can stay on the stage with us.
Caitlin,
what I'd like you to do is approach this a
little more intelligently by dividing and conquering the problem,
but we're going to give you an advantage over Jose.
Kelly has kindly sorted
the numbers from smallest to largest from left to right.
So accordingly,
what's your strategy going to be?
Start in the middle,
OK,
please.
And go ahead as before and reveal to the audience what you found,
not the 50,
the 20,
but what do you know,
Caitlin,
at this point?
Correct.
So the 20 is going to be to the left.
So where might you go next with this 3 locker problem?
Let me propose that
you maybe go to the middle of
the 3.
There we go,
the middle of the middle.
Like that would have been good,
but let's.
Oh no,
oh no,
it's up 100 instead.
You failed,
but what do you know?
It's in the middle that I should have just let you,
but.
Now we have a big round of applause for Kaitlin for having found
the 50 as well.
OK.
So the one catch with this particular demo is that
because they know presumably what monopoly money denominations are,
because we just did this exercise and we had the whole cheat sheet on the board,
you probably had some intuition as to where the 50 was going to be,
even though I was trying to get you to play along.
But in the general case,
if you don't know what the numbers are and that they are the specific denominations,
but you do know that they're going from smallest to largest,
going to the middle,
then the middle of the.
Middle,
then the middle of the middle again and again would have
the effect of starting with a big problem and having it,
having it,
having it just like the phone book as well.
So thanks to you both,
we have these wonderful parting gifts that we found in Harvard Square.
If you like Monopoly,
you'll love the Cambridge edition filled with Harvard Square
name spots.
So thank you to you both,
and a round of applause for our volunteers here.
All right,
so let's see if we can't formalize a little bit these two algorithms known as
linear search insofar as Jose was searching essentially along a line left to right,
and binary search by implying 2 because we were having
that problem in 2 again and again and again.
So for instance.
Linar search from left to right or equivalently right to left,
we could document our pseudo code as follows.
For each door from left to right,
if the 50 is behind the door,
well then we're done.
Just return true.
That's the boolean value which was the goal of this exercise to say yes,
here is the 50.
Otherwise,
at the very bottom of this pseudo code,
we could just say return false because if you get all the way through
the lockers and you have never once declared true by finding the 50,
you might as well default at the very end to saying false,
I did not find it.
But notice here,
just like in week zero when we talked about pseudo code for.
Searching the phone book,
my indentation of all things is actually very intentional.
This version of this code
would be wrong
if I instead used our old friend if else and made this conditional decision.
Why is this code now in red wrong
in terms of correctness?
Yeah.
Exactly,
because if the number 50 is not behind the first door,
the E is telling you right then and there return false.
But as we've seen in C code,
whenever you return a value like that's it for the function,
it is done doing its work.
And so if you return false right away,
not having looked at the other six lockers,
you may very well get the answer wrong.
So the first version of the code where there
wasn't an L but rather this implicit line of
code at the or this explicit line of code at the very end that just says if you.
Reach this line of code returned false,
that addresses that problem.
And to be clear,
even though it's right after an indented return true when you return a value as in C,
that's it like execution stops at that point,
at least for the function or in this case the pseudo code in question.
All right,
so here's a more computer sciencey way of describing the same algorithm
and even though it starts to look a little more arcane,
the reality is when you start using variables
and sort of standard notation you can actually.
Express yourself much more clearly and precisely,
even though it might take a little bit of practice to get used to.
Here is how a computer scientist would
express that exact same ideas instead of saying
for each door from left to right we might throw some numbers on the table.
So for I,
a variable apparently from the value zero on up through the
value and minus 1 is what this shorthand notation means.
If 50 is behind doors bracket I,
so to speak,
so now.
Sort of treating the notion of doors as an array using our notation from last week.
If 50 is behind doors bracket I return true.
Otherwise,
if you get through the entirety of that array of doors,
you can still return false.
Now notice here N minus 1 seems a little weird because aren't there end doors?
Why do I want to go from 0 to N minus 1 instead of 0 to end?
Yeah.
Because um 0 is the first.
Exactly,
if you start counting at 0 and you have n elements,
the last one is going to be addressed as n minus 1,
not N,
because if it were N,
then you actually have N + 1 elements,
which is not what we're talking about.
So again,
just a standard notation and it's a little terser this way.
It's a little more succinct and frankly it's a little more adaptable to code.
And so what you're going to find is
that as our problem sets and programming challenges.
We assign sort of get a little more involved.
It's often helpful to write out pseudo code like this using an amalgam of English,
and C,
and eventually Python code,
because then it's way easier after to just translate your pseudo code
into actual code if you're operating at this level of detail.
All right,
so in the second algorithm where Caitlin kindly searched for 50 again,
but Kelly gave her the advantage of sorting the numbers.
Advance now she doesn't have to just resort to brute force,
so to speak,
trying all possible doors from left to right.
She can be a little more intelligent about it
and pick and choose the locker she opens.
And so with binary search as we call that,
we could implement the same pseudo code or we
could implement pseudo code for it as follows.
We might say if 50 is behind the middle door,
then
go ahead and return true.
Else if it's not behind the middle door,
but 50 is less than that number
behind the middle door,
we want to go and search the left half so that
didn't happen in Caitlin's sense because we ended up going right,
so that's just another branch here.
LA 50 is greater than what was at the middle door.
We want to search the right half,
but there's going to be one other condition here that we should probably consider,
which is what?
Is it here,
is it to the left,
or is it to the right?
But there's another a corner case that we'd better.
Keep track of
what else could happen
if it's not in the ray or really like we're out
of doors so we can implement this in a different way.
I left myself some space at the top because
I shouldn't do any of this if there are no doors to search for,
so I should have this sort of sanity check whereby if
there's no doors left or no doors to begin with,
let's just immediately return false.
And why is that?
Well,
notice that when I say search left half and search right half,
this is implicitly telling me just do.
This again,
just do this again,
but with fewer and fewer doors,
and this is a technique for solving
problems and implementing algorithms that we're going
to end today's discussion on because what
seems very colloquial and very straightforward,
OK,
search the left half,
search the right half,
is actually a very powerful programming technique that's going
to enable us to write more elegant code,
sometimes less code,
to solve problems such as this and more on that
in just a little bit.
But how can we Now formalize this using some of our array notation.
Well,
it looks a little more complicated,
but it isn't really.
Instead of asking questions in English alone,
I might say if 50 is behind doors bracket middle.
This soda code presupposes that I did some
math and figured out what the numeric address,
the numeric index is of the middle element and how can I do that?
Well,
if I've got 7 doors and I divide by 2,
what's that?
7 divide by 2.
3.5,
3.5 makes no sense if I'm using integers to address this,
so maybe we just round down,
so 3,
so that would be locker number 0123,
which indeed if you look at the seven lockers is in fact the middle.
So this is to say using some relatively simple arithmetic,
I can figure out what the address is,
the index is of the middle door.
How many there are and I divide by 2 and round down.
Meanwhile,
if I don't find 50 behind the middle door,
let's ask the question.
If 50 is less than the value at the middle door,
then let's search,
not the left half per se in the general sense,
more specifically search doors 0 through doors bracket
middle minus 1.
Otherwise,
if 50 is greater than the value at the middle door,
go ahead and search doors bracket middle plus 1 through doors bracket and minus 1.
Now let's consider these in turn.
So searching the left half,
as we described this earlier,
seems to line up with this idea like start start searching from doors
0,
the very first one,
but why are we searching
doors
bracket middle minus 1 instead of doors bracket middle?
Yeah.
Yeah,
exactly.
We already checked the middle door by asking this previous question,
so you're just wasting everyone's time if you divide the
half and still consider that door as checkable again.
And same thing here.
We check middle + 1
through the end of the locker's array
because we already checked the middle one.
So same reason,
even though it just kind of complicates the look of the math,
but it's really just using variables and arithmetic
to describe the locations of these same lockers.
But let's consider.
Now what we mean by running time,
the amount of time it takes for an algorithm to run,
and consider which and why
one of these algorithms is better than the other.
So in general,
when talking about running time,
we can actually use pictures like this.
This is not going to be some like very low
level mathematical analysis where we count up lots of values.
It's going to be broad strokes so that we can communicate to colleagues,
to other humans,
generally,
whether an algorithm is better than another and how you might compare the two.
So here for instance is a pictorial analysis of two different algorithms the
phone book from week zero and then the attendance taking from today itself.
And let's generally,
as we've done before,
sort of label these things.
So the very first algorithm took end steps in the very worst case if I had
to search the whole phone book or if I had to count everyone in the room.
So the first algorithm took indeed end steps.
The second algorithm took half as many plus 1 maybe,
but we'll keep it simple.
So we'll call that N over 2.
The third and final algorithm both in week 0 with the phone
book and today with attendance is technically logbase 2 of N.
And if you're a little rusty in your logarithms,
that's fine.
Just take on faith that logba 2 alludes to taking a problem of size N
and dividing it in half and half and half as many times as you can
until you're left with one person standing or one page in the phone book.
That's how many times you can divide in half
a problem of size N.
Well,
it turns out that we're a little more
detailed than most computer scientists care to get
when describing
the efficiency of algorithms.
So in fact we're going to start to use some notation.
Instead of worrying precisely mathematically about how many
steps today's and the future's algorithms take,
we're going to talk in broader strokes about how many steps there are on the order of,
and we're going to use what's called big O notation,
which literally is like a big O and then some parentheses,
and you pronounce it big.
of
such and such.
So the first algorithm seems to be in big O of n,
which means
it's on the order of N steps,
give or take some.
This algorithm here,
you might be inclined to do something similar.
It's on the order of N divided by 2 steps,
and this one's on the order of log based 2 of N steps,
but it turns out what we really care about
with algorithms is how
the time
grows as the problem it.
Self grows in size.
So the bigger end gets,
the more concerned we are over how efficient our algorithm is.
If only because today's computers are so darn fast,
whether you're crunching 1000 numbers or 2000 numbers,
like it's going to take like a split second no matter what.
But if you're crunching 1000 numbers versus
a million numbers versus a billion numbers,
like that's where things start to actually be noticeable by us
humans and we really start to care about these values.
So in general,
when using big O.
like this,
you ignore lower order terms or equivalently you only worry about
the dominant term in whatever mathematical expression is in question.
So big event remains big event.
big O of N over 2,
it's the same thing really as like big O over n.
Like it's not really,
but
they're both linear in nature.
One grows at this rate,
one grows at this rate instead,
but it's for all intents and purposes the same.
They're both growing at a constant rate.
This one too uh it's on the order of log of n where the base is who cares?
In short,
what does this really mean?
Well,
imagine in your mind's eye that we were about to zoom out on this graph
such that instead of going from 0 to like a million,
maybe now the x axis is 0 to a billion,
and same thing for the y axis 0 to a million.
Let's zoom out so you're seeing.
0 to a billion.
Well,
in your mind's eye,
you might imagine that as you zoom out,
essentially things just get more and more compressed visually
because you're zooming out and out and out,
but these things still look like straight lines.
This thing still looks like curved lines,
which is to say as n gets large,
clearly this green algorithm,
whatever it is,
is more appealing,
it would seem
than either of these two.
Algorithms and if we keep zooming out like at some point the ink is going to be
so close together that they all are for all
intents and purposes pretty much the same algorithm.
So this is to say computer scientists don't care about lower order
terms like divide by 2 or base 2 or anything like that.
We look at the most dominant term that really matters is N gets bigger and bigger.
So that then is big O notation.
And
it's something we'll start to use pretty much recurringly any time we
analyze or speak to how good or how bad some algorithm is.
So here's a little cheat sheet of common running times.
So for instance,
here's our friend big O of N,
which means the algorithm takes on the order of end steps.
Here is one that takes on the order of log N steps.
Here are some others we haven't seen yet.
Some algorithms take n times logn steps.
Some algorithms take squared steps,
and some algorithms just take one step,
maybe,
or maybe 2 steps or 4 steps or 10,
but a constant number of steps.
So let me ask,
if the algorithms we've looked at thus far,
for instance,
linear search being the very first today,
what is the running time of linear search
in big O notation?
That is to say,
if there's people,
or if there's N lockers on the stage,
how many steps might it take us to find a number among those
N
lockers?
They go of,
yeah.
Big O of N in fact is exactly where I would put linear search.
Why?
Well,
if you're using linear search in the very worst case,
for instance,
the number you're looking for,
as with Jose,
might be all the way at the end.
So you might get lucky.
It might not be at the very end,
but generally it's useful to use this big O notation
in the context of worst case scenarios because that really gives
you a sense of how badly this algorithm could perform
if you just get really unlucky with your data set.
So even though BigO really just refers to an upper bound,
like how many steps might it take,
it's generally useful to think about it in
the context of like the worst case scenario,
like,
ah,
the number I care about is actually way over here.
But what about binary search?
Even in the worst case,
so long as the data is sorted,
how many steps might binary search take by contrast?
Big O of log in.
So binary search we're going to put here,
which is to say that in general,
and especially as N gets large,
binary search is much faster.
It takes much less time.
Why?
Because assuming the numbers are sorted,
you will be dividing in half and half and half,
just like with the phone book in week 0,
that problem,
and you will get to your solution
much faster.
Why should you not use binary search though
on an unsorted array of lockers?
Like a random
set of numbers,
yeah.
Exactly,
you're making these decisions based on inequalities less than or greater than,
but based on like no rhyme or reason.
You're going left going right,
but there's no reason to believe that smaller numbers
are this way and bigger numbers are that way.
So you're just making incorrect decision after incorrect decision,
so you're probably going to miss the number altogether.
So binary search on an unsorted array is just incorrect,
incorrect usage of the algorithm.
But like Kelly did,
if you sort the data in advance or you're handed sorted data,
well then you can in fact apply binary search perfectly and much more efficiently.
Sure there is more efficient.
Absolutely.
Is Linear search sometimes more efficient if it's going to take you more time
to sort the data and then use binary search?
Absolutely.
And that's going to be one of
the design decisions that underlies any implementation
of an algorithm because if it's going to take you some crazy long time,
not to sort like 7 numbers,
but 70,
700,
7000,
7 million,
but you only need to search the data once,
then what the heck are you doing?
Like why are you wasting time sorting.
Data,
if you only care about getting an answer once,
you might as well just use linear search or heck,
do it even randomly and hope you get lucky if you don't care about reproducing
the same result.
Now,
in general,
that's not how much of the world works.
For instance,
Google's working really hard to make faster and faster algorithms because we
are not searching Google once and then never again doing it.
We're doing it again and again and again so they can amortize.
So to speak,
the cost of sorting data over lots and lots of searches,
but sometimes it's going to be the opposite.
And I think back to graduate school,
where I was often writing code to analyze large sets of data,
and I could have done it the right way,
sort of the CS 50 way,
by fine tuning my algorithm and thinking really hard about my code,
but honestly,
sometimes it was easier to just write really bad but correct code,
go to sleep for 7 hours,
and then my computer would have the answer by morning.
The downside,
as admittedly happened more than once,
is if you have a bug in your code and you go to sleep
and then 7 hours later you find out that there was a bug,
you've just wasted the entire evening,
so there too a trade off sometimes when making those resource decisions.
But that's entirely what today is about making
informed decisions and sometimes maybe it's smarter and wiser
to make the more expensive decision,
but not unknowingly,
at least knowingly.
All right,
so there we have our first two algorithms,
but let's consider another way of describing
the efficiency of an algorithm.
Big O is an upper bound,
sort of how bad can it get in these
cases where maybe the data is really not working to our advantage.
Omega,
a capital Omega symbol here is used for lower bounds.
So maybe how lucky might we get in the best case,
if you will,
how few steps might an algorithm take?
Well,
in this case here,
here's just a cheat sheet of common run times,
even though there's an infinite number of others,
but we'll generally focus on
functions like these.
Let's consider those same algorithms.
So with linear search from left to right,
how few steps might that algorithm take?
For instance,
in like the best case scenario.
Yeah,
is this uh hand about to go up?
so one step why because maybe Jose could have
gotten lucky and opened the door and voila,
that was the 50.
It didn't play out that way,
but it could have.
In the general case,
the number you're looking for could very well be at the beginning.
So we're going to put linear search at omega of 1.
So one step,
and maybe it's technically a few more than that,
but it's a fixed number of steps that Nothing to do with the number of lockers.
Case in point,
if I gave you not 7,
but 70 lockers,
you could still get lucky and still take just one step.
So Omega is our lower bound,
Big O is our upper bound.
Ah,
spoiler,
what is binary search is lower bound.
Well,
apparently it's also omega of 1,
but why?
That is in fact correct,
yeah.
Same reason you could get lucky in the best case,
and it's just smack dab in the middle of all of the data.
So
the fewest number of steps binary search might take is also actually one.
So this is why we talk about upper bound and lower bound because you get kind of a,
a sense of the range of performance.
Sometimes it's going to be super fast,
which is great,
but something tells me in the general case we're not
going to get lucky every time we use an algorithm,
so it's probably going to be closer to those upper bounds,
the big.
Now,
as an aside,
there's a 3rd and final symbol that we
use in computer science to describe algorithms,
that of a capital theta.
Capital theta is jargon you can use when big O and Omega happen to be the same,
and we'll see that today,
not always,
but here's a similar cheat sheet.
None of the algorithms thus far can be described in this way with theta notation
because they are not all the same.
With their big O and Omega,
they differed in both of our analyses,
but we'll see at least one example of one where it's like,
OK,
we can describe this in theta,
and that's like saying twice as much information with your words
to another computer scientist rather than giving them
both the upper and the lower bounds.
The fancy way of describing all of what we're talking about here,
big O,
omega,
and theta
is asymptotic notation,
and asymptotic notation refer or.
Asymptoticle refers to a value getting bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger
but not necessarily ever hitting some boundary as N gets very large.
In short,
is what we mean when we deploy this here asymptotic notation.
All right,
so with the first of these things like linear search,
let's actually kind of make this a bit more real.
Let me actually go over to in just a moment.
Uh my
other screen here,
OK,
in VS code,
let me go ahead and create a program called Search.c.
and in search.c,
let's go ahead and implement a fairly simple version of Linar search initially.
So let me go ahead and include,
for instance,
CS50.h. Let me go ahead and include standardio.h.
Then let me go ahead and do main void,
so we're not going to bother with any command line arguments for now.
And then let me go ahead and just give myself an array of numbers to play with.
And we did this briefly last week in answer to a question,
but I'm going to do it now concretely rather than use something
more manual to get all of these numbers into the array.
I'm going to say give me an array called numbers,
and the numbers I want to put in this array initially are
going to be the exact same denominations we've been playing with 20,
500,
10,
5,
100,
1,
and 50.
Again,
this is a notation that I alluded to in answer to a question last week whereby
if you want.
To statically initialize an array that is give it all of your
values up front without having the human type them all in manually.
You can use curly braces like this,
and the compiler is pretty smart.
You don't have to bother telling the compiler how many numbers you want 1234567
because it can obviously just count how many numbers are in the curly braces,
but you could explicitly say 7 there so long as you're counting is in fact correct.
So on line 6 this gives me an array of 7 numbers.
Initialize to precisely that list of numbers from left to right.
All right,
let's ask the human now what number they want to search for,
just as I did our two volunteers and say in N equals get in,
then let's just ask the user for the number that they want to search for.
Then let's implement linear search.
And if I want to implement linear search in
terms of the programming constructs we've seen thus far,
like what
type,
what keyword in C should I use?
What programming technique,
yeah.
Yeah,
so maybe a 4 loop or a Y loop,
but 4 loop is kind of my go to lately.
So let's do 4 in I equals 0 because we'll start counting from the left.
I is less than 7,
which isn't great to hard code,
but I'm not going to use the 7 again,
so I think it's OK in one place for this demo.
Then I + plus,
then inside of this array.
Let's go ahead and ask a question just like Jose was
by opening each of the doors by saying if numbers 1
equals equals the number we asked about N,
well then let's go ahead and print
out some informative message like found backslashn.
And then for good measure,
like last week,
let's return 0 to signify success.
It's sort of equivalent
to returning true,
but in main recall you have to return an in.
That's why we revealed at the end of week 2 the return type of main
is an in because that is what gives the computer its so-called exit status,
which is zero if all is well,
or anything other.
0 if something went wrong,
but I think finding the number counts is all is well.
But if we get through that whole loop and
we still haven't printed found or returned 0,
I think we can go ahead and safely say not found backslashn,
and then let's just return 1 as our exit status
to indicate that we didn't find the actual number.
So in short,
I think in See this is linear search.
Let me open up my terminal window again.
Let me make search enter.
Let me do search enter,
and I'll search for,
as I asked Jose,
the number 50,
and
we indeed found it at the end.
Let me go ahead and rerunear and let's search
for the other number at the beginning 20.
That then works.
And just to get crazy,
let's search for a number we know not to be there like 1000.
And that in fact
is not found.
So I think we have an implementation then of linear search,
but let me pause here and ask if there's any
questions
with this here code and the translation of algorithm to.
See,
yeah,
in the back.
Why I did not specify the length of the array.
So it is not necessary
when declaring an array
and
setting it equal to some known values in advance to specify in the square
brackets how many you have because like the compiler is not an idiot.
It can literally count the numbers inside.
Of the curly braces and just infer that value you could put it there,
but arguably you're opening up the possibility that you're going to
miscount and you're going to put 7 here but 8 numbers
over there or 6 numbers there so it's best not to
tempt fate and just let the compiler do its thing instead.
A good question.
Other questions
on this code so far.
All right,
if none,
let's go ahead and maybe convert this linear
search to one that's maybe a little more interesting
that involves like searching for strings of text.
After all,
we started the class in week zero by searching
for names in a phone book like John Harbert.
Let's see if we can adapt our code for searching for strings instead of integers.
So in my code here,
let's go ahead and delete everything inside of
Maine just to give myself a clean canvas.
Let me go ahead and give me another array,
this one called,
let's just call it strings because that's the goal of this exercise,
and set them equal to some familiar
pieces from the game of Monopoly if you might have played.
So there's like a battleship piece in there.
There's a boot in there,
there's a cannon in there,
an iron,
a thimble,
and a top hat,
though it does vary nowadays based on the addition that you have.
So kind of a long array,
but I have 123456 total values in this array of strings.
Now let's ask the user for a string.
We'll call it S for short and say with get string,
what string are you looking for among those 6.
Then I think we can do a 4 loop again for in I equals 0,
I less than 6,
I plus plus,
and then inside of this loop,
let's do the same thing
if
Uh,
let's say strings
bracket i
equals equals
the strings that the human typed in.
I think we can go ahead and say print found backslashn and then as before return.
0 to signify success,
and if we don't,
after that whole 4 loop,
let's print print F not found backslash and down here and return 1 to signify error.
So it's really the same
thing at the moment,
except that I'm actually using strings instead.
Integers.
All right,
let me go ahead and open up my terminal window again and clear it.
Let me go ahead and recompile this code.
MakeSearch.c.
Seems to compile OK.
Let me do search and let's go ahead and search for the first one.
How about battleship enter.
Huh,
not found.
All right.
Well,
let's maybe a typo,
maybe.
Let me search for something easier to spell,
boot.
Not found.
That's weird.
Both of those are at the very start of the array.
Let's do slashear again and search for top hat.
Enter.
Not found.
What is going on?
Well,
this isn't actually that obvious as to what I'm doing wrong,
but it turns out that when we actually compare strings instead of integers and see,
we're actually going to have to use this other library,
at least today,
that we saw briefly last week.
Last week we introduced it because of a function called Stirling,
which gives us the length of a string.
Turns out that string.
H also comes per its documentation with
another useful function called Stircom for string.
Compare and its purpose in life is to actually compare two strings
left and right to make sure they are in fact the same.
So for today's purposes,
suffice it to say you cannot use equals equals apparently to compare two strings.
Intuitively,
why is that?
Well,
for a computer it's super easy to compare two integers
because they're either there or they're not in memory.
But with a string,
it's not just a character and another character,
it's like 7.
Characters over here and a few characters over here.
Maybe it's a few,
maybe it's more,
you have to compare each and every character in a
string to make sure they're in fact the same.
So Stir Compare
does exactly that,
probably in the implementation of Stir Co from like years ago
someone wrote a wild loop or a floor loop that looks at
each string left to right and compares each and every one of
the characters they're in and then gives us back an answer.
So how do we go about using this?
Well,
to use stir compare,
what I can actually do in VS code here is
go and change my code as follows.
Instead of using equals equals,
I'm going to actually use this function
per its documentation.
I'm going to call stir compare,
then I'm going to pass in one of the strings,
which is in strings bracket I.
Then I'm going to pass in the second string,
which is S.
However,
having read the documentation,
and this is a little nonobvious,
it turns out that
Comp will return 0 if the strings are equal.
Otherwise it's going to return a positive number
or a negative number.
So what I care about for now is does the
return value of stir comp when given those two strings,
give me back zero?
If so,
they are equal and I'm going to say unquote found.
So let's go ahead and open the terminal again.
Let me go ahead and clear it and do make search to recompile my code
and huh.
I've done something wrong.
Let's see.
Let me scroll up to the very
first line in line 11 error call to undeclared library function stir comp
would type in and something something which gets more complicated after that.
Why is line 11 not working despite what I just preached?
Yeah.
Yeah,
I just did something stupid.
I didn't include the string.h header library,
so all
clang our compiler is doing when invoked by Make
is it's encountering literally the word stir comp and
not knowing what it is because we haven't taught
it what it is by simply saying include string.
H at the top.
OK,
let me reopen my terminal window,
clear that message.
Way to make search again.
Now it's compiling search enter.
Now I'm going to go ahead and search as I did before for Battleship.
Ah,
now it's finding it.
Let me run ear again.
Search for boot.
Ah,
OK,
that's found.
Let me go ahead and search for top hat.
That too is in there.
Let me go ahead and search for something that's not there like the number 50.
Not in fact found,
so I think we've actually fixed that their problem.
But if we go back to this code for a moment,
it's indeed the case for the documentation that equals equals 0 is what I want to do.
Why in the world would Stir comp
be designed to return a positive or a negative number 2?
It's not returning true or false,
it's returning one of three possible values zero,
negative or positive.
Why might it be useful?
Yeah.
Um,
you could kind of like compare which of the ring is like.
Yeah,
super clever.
So if you're passing in two strings,
it's great to know if they're equal,
but wouldn't it be nice if this same function could also help us
sort these strings ultimately and tell me which one comes first alphabetically?
And technically it's not going to be alphabetically,
it's going to be a cute phrase askibetically because
it's actually going to look at the asy values of
the characters and do some quick arithmetic and tell you
which one comes first and which one comes later,
which is enough.
We'll eventually see for actually sorting these strings as well.
So in short,
the documentation will tell me that I should check
not only for zero if I care about equality,
but if I care about inequality,
that's checking if one comes first or last,
I should check whether something is less than 0 or greater than.
But for this demonstration,
implementing linear search,
I don't care about comparing them
for inequality.
All I care about is that they are in fact the same
or Not
in this case.
All right,
well,
let's go ahead and do one other
example of sort of linear search,
but let's make the problem more like that actually
in week zero of searching a phone book.
So let me go back to VS code here.
Close search.c and let's make an actual phone book.
So I'm going to say code of phonebook.c and then
inside of phonebook.c let's use our same header file.
So include CS50.
H,
includes standard IO.
Dot and let's include an advance
string.h.
Then let's as before do in main void,
no command line arguments today.
Then inside of here,
let me give myself first an array of strings.
How about some names in the phone book?
So I'm going to say string,
names,
equals,
and then three names just to make a demonstration.
Kelly and David and say John Harvard here.
But if it's a phone book,
I need more than just names.
So let me go ahead and give myself another.
Array string of numbers open bracket close bracket equals and
now the same phone numbers we used in week zero
for the three of us plus 1 617495 1000
same for both Kelly and me,
so plus 1,
1000.
And then as before,
if you'd like to text or call John directly,
you can do so at plus 1-949-4682750 and semicolon.
So
one question first,
I obviously declared our names to be
an array of strings because that's what text is.
Why have I also declared phone numbers to be strings and not integers because
a phone number is like literally a number in the name of it,
yeah.
Yeah,
so even though we have phone numbers in the US,
even though we have Social Security numbers and a
bunch of other things that we call numbers,
if you have other non-digits in those,
in those values,
you have to actually use strings because if it's not an actual integer,
but it does have things like pluses or dashes
or parentheses or any other form of punctuation,
as is common in the US and other countries for phone numbers in particular,
you're going to actually want to use strings and not.
as well as for corner cases like if there are if you're in the habit back home,
if you're not from say the US and you actually have
to dial 0 1st to make like a local regional call,
you don't want to have a leading zero
in an
integer because mathematically,
as we know from grade school like leading zeros,
number 0s that come first have no mathematical meaning,
they're going to disappear
effectively from the computer's memory unless we store them
in fact as characters in strings in this way.
OK,
with that said,
let's go ahead and ask the human now after having declared those two
arrays for the name they want to look up the number of.
So let's say string name equals get string,
and let's go ahead and ask the human
for the name for which to search.
Then let's use a 4.
As before,
for in i equals 0,
I less than 3,
which again for demonstration purposes I'm just hard coding today I + plus and
then in the 4 loop I'm going to use our new friend Stircom if
the return value of stircompare passing in names bracket I.
And the name the human typed in equals equals
zero signifying that they are in fact the same.
Well,
that means we found
the location I
where the person's name is.
So let's go ahead and print out found,
but just to be fun,
let's print out whom we found.
So percent F.
Backslash N and then output there
the number which is going to be in the corresponding numbers array at that
same location I will return 0 and at the very end of this program,
let's go ahead and print out not found if we get that far
and return 1.
All right,
so a little more complexity this time,
but notice I'm comparing the names just like a normal person would in
your iOS app or your Android app when looking for someone's name,
but what I care about is getting back the number.
So that's why two lines later,
I'm printing out the number that I found at location I,
not the name,
because I already know the name.
All right.
In my terminal window,
let's go ahead and make this phone book.
phonebook.
Let's go ahead and search for John,
whose number is hopefully
indeed exactly that number.
So suffice it to say this code 2 does work.
This is a linear search because I'm searching left to right.
These aren't actually sorted alphabetically by name or let alone number.
So I think we're doing well here
but
I don't necessarily love this implementation
even if you're new to programming,
what might you not like
about how I've implemented a phone book in the computer's memory?
Why is this maybe not the best design,
yeah.
OK,
yeah,
and I would say,
so you're pointing out that we have this duality.
We've got two arrays.
They're the exact same length,
and it just so happens that location zero's name lines up
with location 0's number and location 1 and location 2,
but we're kind of on the honor system here whereby the
onus is on us to make sure we don't screw this
up and we make sure we always have the same number
of names and the same number of numbers and better and moreover
that we may get the order exactly.
right,
we are just trusting that when we print out the IT number,
so to speak,
that it lines up with the IT name.
So that's fine.
And honestly for 3 people who really cares,
it's fine,
but if you think about 30 people,
300,
3 million,
well we're not going to hard code them all here,
but even in some database
that will store them in later in the course feels like just trusting
that we're not going to screw this up is asking for trouble.
And indeed a lot of programming is just that,
like not trusting yourself.
And definitely not trusting your colleague not to mess something up,
but programming a bit more defensively and trying to encapsulate
related information a little more tightly together and not just assume,
as on the honor system that these two independent arrays will line up.
But at this point we have no means of solving this problem
unless we give ourselves just a bit new functionality and syntax.
So I used this phrase earlier to kick things off.
Data structures.
It's like how you structure your data in the computer's memory.
Arrays are the simplest of data structures.
They just store data back to back to back from left to right contiguously in memory,
but they all have to be,
as we've seen,
the same kinds of values in,
in,
or string,
string string.
There's no mechanism yet for storing an in and a string together,
and then another in and another string together,
or let alone two strings,
2 strings,
2 strings
that are somehow a little bit different.
But
it would be nice if C gave us an actual data type to store
people in a phone book such that we could create an array called people
inside of which is going to be a whole bunch of persons,
if you will,
back to back to back,
and I want two of them.
So wouldn't it be nice if I could literally use this code and see?
Well,
decades ago when Sem was invented,
they didn't give us a person data type.
All we have is in and float and char and bull and string and so forth.
Person was not among the available data types,
but we can invent our own data types it turns out.
So in see what we can do if we want persons to exist
and every person in the world shall have a name and a phone number for now,
we can do this.
Name string number.
Now that's a decent start,
but it's going to be kind of a stupid implementation
if I then just do name string name 1,
string name 2,
string name 3,
string name 4.
We've already
started down that road last week and decided arrays were a better solution.
But here's an alternative when you want to just store related data together.
I can use these two keywords and see type death struct,
which albeit terse,
just means define a new type
that is a data structure.
So multiple things together
inside the curly braces you literally put the
two things you want to relate together.
Name string number and then outside the curly braces you specify
the name you want to give to this brand new custom type
that you have invented.
Technically,
stylistically,
you'll see that Style 50 prefers that the name
actually be on the same line as the last curly brace,
which looks a little weird to me,
but that's what industry tends to do so
so be it.
But these several lines together tell C
invent for me a new data type called person and assume that every person
in the world has a string called name and a string called number.
And now I can use this new data type
in my own code to solve this problem
a little bit better.
So in fact,
let me go ahead and do this as follows.
I'm going to go back to VS code here and at the
very top of my code above main just to make this.
Available to not only main but maybe any future functions I write.
I'm going to say type destruct,
as we saw on the screen.
Inside of my curly braces,
I'm going to say string name and
string number,
and then I'm going to name this thing person.
Now I'm going to go about using this and I'm going to go ahead and delete my previous
honor system approach of having names and numbers in separate arrays,
and I'm instead going to give myself an array
of people.
We can call it persons,
but I'm trying to be somewhat grammatically correct,
so I'm going to say people bracket 3
to give myself an array,
call people
inside of which is room for 3 persons,
inside of which is room for a name and number each.
So how do I now initialize these values?
Well,
I'm going to hard code them,
that is type them manually,
but you can imagine using get string or get or some
other function to get this data from the human themselves.
I'm going to say
go to the people array at location 0.
And access the name field,
and this is syntax we haven't seen yet,
but it's not that hard.
You literally use a dot,
a single period,
to say go inside of that structure and access the name field,
the name attribute,
so to speak,
and let's set that equal to Kelly.
Then let's go into that same array location,
people bracket 0 and set the number for the zeroth person
to be plus 1617495 1000.
Then let's go ahead and do the same thing for people 1.
Set that person's name to,
for instance,
mine,
David.
Then let's do people bracket 1.n number equals quote unquote,
same as Kelly because we're both in the directory.
So plus 1 617495
1000.
And then lastly,
people bracket 2.name equals quote unquote for John Harvard,
people 2.n number equals plus 1.
949-4682750 in this case.
And now the rest of the code is almost the same.
I'm going to now on the new line 24 still ask the user what name they want.
I'm going to still iterate from 0 to 3 because there's still 3 elements in this array,
even though each has two values within,
and I'm Compare now not names,
but people bracket I.name to go access the name of that person
and compare it to the name
that the human has typed in.
And when I find that person,
I'm going to go into the people array at location I but print out
the number instead.
So all we've done here is add this dot notation which
allows you to access the inside of a data structure,
and all we've done is introduce up here some new C keywords that let you
invent your own data types inside of which you can put most anything you want.
I have chosen a string name and a string number.
All right,
let me go ahead and open my terminal window and clear it from before.
Let me do make Phonebook to make this version.
So far so good.
Make Phonebook enter.
I'm going to go ahead now and search for say John.
And I have again found his number,
so this is still correct,
but even though this took more minutes in terms of
the voiceover and it took more lines of code,
it's arguably better designed now because at people bracket
0 is an actual person in everything about them.
At people bracket 1 is another person in everything about them.
And so forth.
This is what we mean by encapsulate,
you can think of these curly braces as sort of hugging
these
data types inside of the data structure together so as to keep them together
in the computer's memory as well.
All right,
well,
just to set the stage,
uh,
literally,
as we'll strike the lockers and put something else up,
the efficiency of binary search as implemented by Caitlin was predicated
on Kelly having in advance sorted the values up front.
But of course we've only considered now the running
time of searching for information using two algorithms,
and there can be many others.
In the real world,
but those are two of the most canonical.
We found that binary search was faster
than linear search,
but it required that we sort the data.
So to your question earlier,
maybe we should consider just how expensive it is in terms of time,
money,
space,
humans to sort data,
especially a lot of data,
and then decide whether or not it's worth using
something like binary search or perhaps even something else.
So.
The next problem we'll solve today ultimately is given generic input and output.
The input to our next problem is going to be unsorted data,
so like numbers out of order,
the output of which should be sorted data.
So for instance,
if we pass in 72541,
603,
I want whatever black box is implementing
my sorting algorithm to spit out 01234567.
So that's going to be the question we answer.
But first I think it's time for some delightful Hello Pandass chocolate biscuits.
Uh,
let's take a 10 minute break and snacks are now served.
All
right,
we are back and recall that the cliffhanger on which we
left was that how do we go about sorting numbers?
Well,
here are some numbers,
8 of them in fact,
from 0 to 7,
but currently unsorted.
Um,
we don't quite have enough monopoly boards for everyone,
but we do have some delightful,
uh.
For Mario Brothers Pez dispensers,
if I could get 8 volunteers for this final demo up here,
oh,
and not a lot of hands.
OK,
all right,
123456,
and let's go farther back 7 and 8.
How about alright,
come on up
hopefully I counted properly.
Come on over.
Upon arrival at the stage,
go ahead and grab your favorite illuminated number
and stand in that same order at the front of the stage if you all could.
Welcome to the stage.
All right,
grab your favorite number,
stand in that same order.
All right.
Good.
And 123456.
I definitely said 1 through 8.
Who is the number 8 then?
OK,
we need an 8.
Come on down.
All right.
Well,
technically we need a 4,
but come on down.
Yeah.
All right,
grab the 4 and let me start from this end first if you
want to give a quick hello and a little something about you.
Uh,
hi,
my name is Cameron.
I'm a first year and I want to study mechanical engineering.
Welcome.
Hi,
I'm Charlotte.
I'm also first year and I'm in Canada F.
Welcome.
Hi,
I'm Ella.
I'm also a first year and I'm in Thayer.
Hi,
I'm Precious.
I'm also a first year.
I'm in the.
Hi,
I'm Michael.
I'm just an Eventbrite guest.
Hi,
I'm Marie.
I'm a first year and I'm in Canada.
Welcome.
Hi,
I'm Rick.
I'm a first year and I'm in Holworthy.
Nice.
I'm Jay.
I'm a 1st year in Holworthy and I really like free stuff.
OK,
well,
let's see then,
uh,
if we can't award all these supermarket,
but there's Pez dispensers.
The first notice,
of course,
that all 8 of our volunteers are completely out of order,
but in an ideal world we would have the smallest number over here.
So
go over there,
number 0.
Wait a minute.
7,
take over here.
2,
OK,
make yourselves look like that.
No pez.
It's OK.
All right,
so 72541603.
OK,
we won't do the introductions again,
but now we have a list of numbers completely out of order
and wouldn't it be nice if zero were eventually over here?
7 were all the way over there and
everything else was sorted from smallest to largest.
Well,
if you all could go ahead and sort yourselves from smallest to largest,
go.
Alright,
and uh Jayden,
what was your algorithm for doing that?
Um,
I
I,
I know that I have the least number because I
don't think anybody has the number less than 0,
so I put myself at the
last bottom line.
OK,
and I assume Precious,
what was your algorithm?
I knew I had the largest numbers,
so I just had to be at the end of the.
OK,
fair.
So you guys got the easy ones.
Uh,
number 4.
How about
You knew 3 was before me and 5 was after me.
Nice.
And number 4 didn't actually have to move coincidentally,
but as for 5 and 3 and 2 and 1 and 6,
they probably had to take into account some additional information.
Who's to their left,
who's to their right,
and it just kind of worked,
but it didn't look very algorithmic,
if you will.
It looked very organic and obviously correct,
but I'm not sure that same approach would work well if we
had not 8 but 80 or 800 or 8000 pieces of data.
So let's see if we can't form.
I this a little bit.
Let me take the mic and if you guys could reset yourselves to those
same original positions from 7 on the left to 3 on the right,
let me propose a couple of algorithms,
canonical ones if you will,
but see if maybe we can't formalize step by step what to do.
So the first one I'm going to do,
given all of these numbers,
is just try to select the smallest number.
Why?
To Jayden's point earlier,
I just want to put the smallest number over here.
At least that's a problem I can solve.
Well defined.
It's a nice bite out of the problem.
So 7,
OK,
it's the smallest so far.
2,
that's that's smaller.
So I'm going to remember that 2 is the now smallest number I've seen,
not 5,
not 41 is even smaller.
So I'm going to remember 1,
not 60.
That's pretty good,
but I'm going to check the whole list.
Maybe there's -1 or something like that,
but no,
3.
So I'm going to remember that 0 was the smallest element I found.
Let's select Jaden and put Jayden over here,
but
Before Precious or anyone else moves,
we don't really have room for you.
Like Precious is in the way because if this is an array
of 8
values for integers,
well,
we can't just kind of make room over here because if you think back to last week,
we might have some garbage values there or something else is going on.
We don't want to change data that doesn't belong to us.
So what to do with?
Well,
maybe precious,
maybe you can go over there.
So you just take Jade in spots and we'll swap these two values.
Accordingly,
now though,
Jayden is in the right space,
which is good because now I can move on to the second problem.
What's the next smallest element that's presumably greater than 0?
Well,
at the moment 2 is the next smallest element,
not 5,
not 401 is the next smallest element.
I'm going to remember that not 6,
not 7,
not 3.
OK,
so number 1,
if you could go to the right location,
but I'm afraid we're going to have to evict number 2 to make room.
All right,
let's do this again.
0 and 1 are in good shape,
so now I think I can ignore them as complete.
5 is the current smallest.
No,
4 now is no.
2 now is
so 2 is the next smallest.
So let's swap 2 and 5,
and now I've solved 3 out of the 8 problems.
Let's do this again.
4 is at the moment the smallest,
not 5,
not 6,
not 3 is the now smallest.
So let's swap 34 and 3.
Which unfortunately is making the 4 problem a little worse,
like he belongs there,
it would see,
but I think we can fix that later.
So now half of the list is sorted.
5 is the next smallest,
6 and 74,
and then we've got to fix the 4,
so 4 goes back there.
Now I messed up the 5,
but it will come back to that.
All right,
67,
OK,
5.
Let's put you where 6 is,
and One more mistake to fix,
so 7,
OK,
6 and 7 need to swap.
And now I've solved 8 problems in the aggregate,
so it's complete.
Now to be fair,
my approach is clearly way slower than your approach,
but you all were working in parallel,
whereas I was doing it more methodically step by step,
and I dare say my algorithm is probably going to be more translatable to code.
And indeed what I Just acted out is what the
world would call selection sort whereby on each iteration,
each pass in front of the humans,
I was selecting the smallest element I could find.
All right,
what,
how else could I do this though?
Let's do something that's maybe a little more
organic like your approach where you were actually comparing who was next to you.
Go ahead and reset yourselves one final time to this arrangement.
7 on the left,
3 on the right,
and let me propose again to walk through the list again and again,
but let me focus more narrowly on the problem right in front of me
because I felt like I was taking a lot of steps back and forth,
back and forth.
Maybe we can chip away at some of that wasted time.
Let's compare 7 and 2.
They're obviously out of order,
so let's just immediately swap you two if we could.
All right,
now 7 and 5,
clearly out of order.
Let's swap these two.
7 and 4 out of order.
Let's swap these 27 and 1 out of order,
let's swap these 2.7 and 6 out of order.
Let's swap these 2.7 and 0 out of order,
swap these two.
73 out of order,
So a lot of work for Precious there,
but I've now indeed solved one of the eight problems.
Moreover,
I don't need to keep addressing the 7 problem because notice that Precious
has essentially bubbled her way up to the end of the list.
And indeed that's going to be the operative term here.
Another algorithm
that computer scientists everywhere know is called bubble sort,
whereby the goal is to get the biggest elements to just bubble their way up to the.
Top of or the end of the list one at a time.
Now,
am I done?
No,
clearly not.
There's still stuff out of order except for Precious.
Indeed,
I have solved one of these eight problems and now fine,
I'll go back and I'm just going to try this same logic again 2 and 5,
good,
5 and 4,
nope,
swap those 5 and 1,
swap those
5 and 6 are good.
6 and 0,
nope,
swap those 6 and 3,
swap those.
And I already know that.
Precious is where she needs to be,
so I think I'm done with the second of 8 problems,
and I'll do this a little faster now.
2 and 44 and 1 swap,
4 and 5 are good,
5 and 0 swap,
5 and 3 swap,
and now we've solved 3 problems.
Let me reset 2 and 1 swap,
2 and 4 are good,
4 and 0 swap,
4 and 3 swap,
and now I've solved half of the problems.
4 out of 8,
we're almost done.
1 and 2 are good,
2 and 0 swap.
2 and 3 are good,
OK,
and now we're done with 5 out of the 8 problems,
1 and 0 swap.
Uh,
1 and 2 are good.
Those are all good.
And let me just do a final sanity check.
Everything now is sorted,
so now I'm done solving all eight of those problems.
So you all were wonderful.
We need the numbers back,
but Kelly has some delightful Pez dispensers for you on
the way out if you want to head that way,
just leave the numbers on the shelves and a round of
applause for our 8 volunteers for helping to act this out.
Thank you.
So
let's see if we can't formalize what these volunteers kindly just did with us,
starting with the first of those algorithms,
thank you,
namely selection sort.
Let's see if we can't slap some pseudo code on this,
thinking of our humans now as more generically in array.
So we had the first person at location 0 and
we had the last person at location N minus 1.
And just for clarity so that you've kind of seen the symbology,
this obviously is going to be location N minus 2.
Location and minus 3 and so forth until it's sort of
you hit the other end that we've already written out.
So that's just how we refer to all of our
8 volunteers' locations or in this case 1234567 locations,
but in the middle connoting that this can be a much,
much larger array.
So here's some pseudo code for the first algorithm
selection sort for I from 0 ton minus 1.
So from the first element
to the last element,
find the smallest number between.
The numbers bracket I and numbers
and minus 1.
In other words,
if you're starting I at 0,
look at specifically every lighted number between 0 and location N minus 1.
When you have found that smallest element,
swap it
with the number at location I,
which starts again at 0.
That's how we got,
I think,
Jaden into place at the very beginning.
Then I,
by nature of how 4 loops work,
gets updated from 0 to 1 so that we do the same thing.
Find the smallest number between numbers 1,
so the second element through the 8th element because this
number is unchanged and is the total number of values,
so the end point there is not changing.
Once we found the second smallest person,
we swap them with.
Location I aka 1,
and that's how we got the number 1 into position and then
the number 2 and then the number 3 and number 4.
So this then was selection sort in pseudo code form
and that allowed us to actually go through this list
again and again and again in order to find the next smallest element.
So what was happening a little more methodically if it helps just to map
that symbology of the bracket notation in the eyes,
if this is where we started with location I
and we did everything between location and minus 1.
Essentially I traversed this whole list from left to right,
literally walking in front of our volunteers looking at each element,
and the first element I saw was 7.
At the moment that was the smallest element I had found,
and who knows,
in a different list.
Maybe 7 would be the smallest element,
so I kind of stored it in a variable in my mind,
but I checked then 2 and remembered,
no,
2 is clearly less than now I'm going to remember 2.
OK,
now I'm going to remember one when I find it,
and then I'm going to remember 0 when I find it,
and then what I did once I found jade in it with the value of 0,
light it up.
I moved that location to here
and then evicted Precious recall and moved Precious over
to that location that we had freed up.
Why?
Why all this sort of back and forth?
Well,
you have to assume with an array that you're not entitled to the memory over here.
You're not entitled to the memory over here if you've
already decided that you have 7 lockers or 8 people,
you have to commit to the computer in advance.
That's why we put the number typically in the square brackets or the
compiler infers from the curly brackets how big the array actually is.
All right,
and suffice it to say when I went through this again and again and again,
I did the same thing over and over.
Now you might have thought me sort of dumb for having
asked the same.
Questions again and again like I was surprised to discover the number 1.
I was surprised to discover the number 2,
even though on my very first pass I literally looked at all eight of those numbers.
But you have to think about what memory I'm actually using
now.
I certainly could have memorized all of the numbers and where they are,
but I proposed that just very simply I was using like a single
variable in my brain just to keep track of the then smallest element.
And once I'm done finding that
and solving that problem,
I moved on to do it again and again.
But that's going to be a trade off,
and this is going to be thematic in the coming weeks whereby,
well,
sure you could use more memory and I could have been smarter about it
and maybe that would have improved or hurt the running time of the algorithm.
There's often going to be a trade-off between how much memory or how much time
you actually use.
So we'll discover that over time.
So how fast or slow is selection sort?
Well,
consider when I had 8 humans on stage,
I first went through.
Uh,
all of them,
but how many comparisons did I make?
Really,
I was doing N minus 1 comparisons because if I've got N people,
I've got to compare the smallest number I found against everyone else,
and you compare
N people left to right,
N minus 1 times total.
So the first pass I was making,
I was asking N minus 1 questions.
Is this the smallest?
Is this the smallest N minus 1 times?
Once I solved one problem when we got Jayden into Jayden's right place,
then
I had one fewer problem,
then.
One fewer fewer problem and so forth.
So it was like n minus 1 steps plus
N minus 2 steps plus N minus 3 steps plus one final
step once I got to the final of the eight problems.
Now if you remember kind of the cheat sheet at the back of your math books,
say growing up,
you'll note that this series here can be more simply written as N times N minus 1,
all divided by 2.
And if you've not seen that before,
just take on faith that this is identical to this series of numbers up here.
So now we can just kind of multiply this out.
So that's technically n2 minus N all divided by 2,
which is great if we multiply that out,
that's n2d over 2 minus n over 2.
We're getting 2 into the weeds.
Let's whip out our big O notation now whereby we
can wave our hands at the lower order terms,
only care about the biggest,
most dominant term which mathematically in this expression,
if you plug in a really big value of n,
which is going to matter more the N squared,
the 2,
the N,
or the 2.
Like the N squared,
like the others absolutely contribute to the total value,
but if you plug in a really big value,
the dominant force is going to be this n squared
because that's really going to blow up the total value.
So we can say that selection sort when analyzed in this way,
ah,
it's on the order of n squared steps because I'm doing so many comparisons
so many times.
So if that's the case,
the question then is,
Um,
what is indeed not just its upper bound but
maybe it's lower bound as we'll eventually see.
So for selection sort for now,
let's stipulate that it's indeed in big O of N2,
and that's actually the worst of the algorithms we've seen.
Like that's way slower than linear search because at
least linear search was big O of N.
Selection sort is n square,
which of course is n times n,
which is and will feel much,
much slower than that.
So what if though we consider the lower bound of selection sort?
All right,
maybe it's bad in the worst case,
but maybe it's really good when the numbers are mostly sorted.
Unfortunately this is the same pseudo code for selection sort.
We make no allowance for checking the list to make sure it's already sorted,
and in fact that's kind of a perverse case to consider for any algorithm.
What if the problem's already solved?
How's your algorithm going to perform?
All of my volunteers,
as they kind of almost did accidentally,
they started lining up roughly in order.
Suppose they literally had been in order from 0 to 7.
Well,
my stupid algorithm would still have me walking back and forth,
back and forth,
back and forth.
Why?
Because the code literally tells me do this this many times
and every time I do that find the smallest element.
So it's going to be sort of a stupid output
because the list is not going to be any change,
any any at all changed,
but my code is not
taking into account in any way.
The original order of the numbers.
So no matter what,
this is to say that if we consider whether the lockers or the humans,
the omega notation for this algorithm,
even in the best case where the data is already sorted,
is crazily
also
n squad.
Now I could certainly change the pseudo code,
but selection sort as the world knows it is more of a.
Constrative algorithm or sort of a quick and dirty one,
its running time is going to be in omega of N2,
and now we can actually deploy our fader notation
because the big O notation is N2d and the omega notation is n2 1 and the same.
We can also say that selection sort is in theta of N2,
which is not great because that's annoyingly slow.
So maybe the solution here is don't do that.
Let's use bubble sort instead.
The second algorithm where I just compared everyone side by side again and again.
Well,
here's some pseudo code for bubbleor,
which you can assume applies to the same kind of array
from 0 on up to n minus 1.
Here's one way to write bubble sort.
Repeat the following N times.
For I,
from 0 ton minus 2,
if the number at location I
and the number at location I + 1 are out of order,
swap them.
And there's kind of an elegance to this algorithm and that like that's
it and you just assume that when you go through the list,
this is how from I from 0 ton minus 2,
this is how I was effectively comparing elements 0 and 11 and 22 and 33 and 476 and 7,
but notice I didn't say 8,
there were 8 total people.
Why do we go from 0 ton minus 2 instead of
from 0 ton minus 1?
Uh,
yeah.
Yeah
You already checked the glass.
Not quite.
So it's not that we've already checked the last one.
I'm saying with this line of code here,
we never even go to N minus 1 technically.
If we have N minus 345,
and it's going to compare against N minus 1 because that's.
Exactly,
because we're doing this simple arithmetic here,
we're checking current location I plus 1.
You can think of these as my left and right hand.
Left hand is pointing at 0,
right hand's pointing at 1.
I don't want to do something stupid and have my left hand point at N minus 1
because then my right hand arithmetically when you add 1 is going to point at N,
which does not exist.
That's beyond the boundary of the array because the array goes from 0
ton minus 1.
So just a live.
A bit of a safety check there to make sure we don't walk right off the end of the array,
but we do this end times because recall that Precious ended up being where
7 needed to be at the very end of the list,
but that didn't mean there weren't 77 more problems still to solve 0 through 6.
So I did it again and I did it again and per its name bubble sort,
the biggest element bubbled up first,
then the next biggest,
then.
biggest that is 7,
then 6,
then 5,
then 4,
and we got lucky on some of them,
but eventually we finished with 0.
So how do we analyze this thing?
Well,
we could also technically do this N minus 1 times as an aside if
you're thinking through that I'm wasting some time because we get one for free.
Once we get to
solving 7ve problems,
you get the 8th 1 for free because that person is obviously where they need to go.
So when we had these numbers initially,
And we were comparing them with bubbleword again,
left hand right hand.
It's like treat this as I,
this is I plus 1,
and we just kept swapping
pair wise numbers if in fact they were out of order.
So all this is saying is what our humans were doing for us organically.
So how do we actually analyze the running time of this?
Last time I just kind of spitballed that it was minus 1 steps plus N minus 2 steps.
Well,
you can actually look at pseudocode sometimes and if it's neatly written,
you can actually Infer from the pseudo code how many steps each line is going to take.
For instance,
how many steps does this first line take?
I mean,
like literally n minus 1.
The answer is right there because it's saying to the computer or to me acting it out,
repeat the following N minus 1 times.
All right,
so that's helpful.
How many lines,
how many steps does this inner loop
induce?
Well,
you're going from 1 ton minus 2,
so that's actually N minus 1,
total steps,
not n.
And then this question here,
if numbers bracket 1 and numbers 1 are out of order,
it's a single question.
It's like our Boolean expression,
we'll call it one.
I mean,
maybe you need to do a bit of more work than that,
but it's a constant number of steps.
Doesn't matter how big the list is,
comparing two numbers is always going to take the same amount of time.
And then swapping them,
oh,
I don't know,
it's going to take like 1 or 2 or 3 steps,
but constant doesn't matter which the numbers are,
takes the same amount of work.
So let's stipulate,
let me rewind,
stipulate that the real things that matter
are the loops,
these constant number of steps,
who really cares?
But the loops are what are going to add up as N gets large.
So this really then is.
If this is the outer loop
and this is the inner loop,
think about our two dimensional Mario square from week one.
We did something on the outside and then something
on the inside to get our rows and columns.
This is equivalent to N minus 1 times N minus 1.
If we do our little foil method N2 minus N minus N + 1 combined like terms,
N2 minus 2 N + 1,
who cares?
This is ultimately going to be on the order of big O of.
N squared only because again if you ask yourself when
I plug in a really big value for N,
which of these is really going to contribute most to the answer,
it's obviously going to be n2d again and we can ignore the lower order terms.
So this doesn't seem to have made any progress.
Like selection sort was on the order of big events was on the order of N2d.
Bubble sort,
based on this analysis is.
Also on the order of N2d,
maybe we're getting lucky in the lower bound.
So on the upper bound for bubble sort,
it's indeed N2d,
as was selection sort.
But with this pseudo code for bubble sort,
unfortunately
we,
or rather unfortunately we were not doing anything clever
to catch that perverse case where maybe the list was already sorted.
After all,
consider if the list was sorted from 0 to.
I was still asking all the same darn questions.
Even if I did no work,
I was going to repeat that n minus 1 times back and forth,
making no swaps,
but making all of those comparisons.
But here's an enhancement to Bobble So that we can
add that selection So didn't really have room for.
I can say after one pass of this inner loop walking from left to right,
if I made no swaps,
quit.
So put another way,
if I traversed the list from left to right,
I make no swaps.
I might as well just terminate the algorithm then.
Because
there's no more work clearly to be done.
All right,
so based on that
modification,
the lower bound of bubble sorts running time
would be said to be an omega then of.
And
because I'm minimally going to need to make one pass through the list.
You can't possibly claim that the list is sorted unless you actually check it once.
And if there's an elements,
you're going to have to look at all of them to make sure that it's in order.
But after that,
if you've done no work and made no swaps,
no reason to traverse the list again and again and again.
So
a bubble sort can be said to be an omega of N because indeed we can just terminate.
After that single pass if we've done no work,
we can't say anything about theta because they're not
one and the same big O and Omega,
but that does seem to have given us some savings.
Unfortunately,
it really only saves us time when the list is already or mostly sorted,
but in the average case and in the worst case,
odds are they're both going to perform just as bad on the order of n2.
In fact,
let's take a look at a visualization that will make this
a little clearer than our own humans and voices might have.
Explained here is a bunch of vertical purple bars made
by a friend of ours in the real world,
and this is an animation that has a bunch
of buttons that lets us execute certain algorithms.
A small bar represents a small number.
A big bar represents a big number,
and the goal is to get them from small numbers or
small bars to big numbers or big bars left to right.
So I'm going to go ahead and click on selection sort initially,
and what you'll see from left to right
is in pink the current smallest element.
That's been discovered,
but also in pink,
the equivalent of my walking across the stage left to right
again and again and again trying to find
the next smallest element and you'll see clearly
just like when we put Jayden at the far left,
the smallest element ended up over here,
but it might take some time for Precious,
for instance,
or number 7 to end up all the way over on the right because
with each pass we're really just fixing one problem at a time and there's N
problems total,
which is giving us on the order of.
N squared steps and now the list is getting shorter,
so we're at least doing some work that you don't have to
keep touching the elements you already sorted with just like I was.
So now selection sort is complete.
Let's visualize instead bubble sort.
So let me re-randomize the array just so we're starting with a random order.
Now let's click on bubble sort and you'll
see the pink bars work a little differently.
It connotes which two numbers are being compared at that moment in time,
just like my left hand and right hand going left to right,
and you'll see that even though it's not quite as pretty.
A selection sort where I was getting at least
the smallest elements all the way to the left.
Here we're just fixing pair wise problems,
but
the biggest elements like Precious's number 7 are indeed
bubbling their way up to the top one after
the other.
But as you can see,
and this is where n2d is sort of visual visualizable,
we're touching these elements or looking at them so many times again and again.
We are making so many darn comparisons.
This is taking frustratingly long,
and this is only what,
a few dozen bars or numbers.
You can imagine how long this might take with hundreds,
thousands or millions of values.
I dare say we're gonna have to do better than bubble sort and
Selection sort because we're not stun even yet,
just trying to give the satisfaction of getting to the end and now we are,
but neither of those algorithms seems incredibly performing because
it's still taking us quite a bit of time
to actually get to that there solution.
So how can we actually do better than that?
Well,
we can try taking a fundamentally different approach,
and this is one technique that you might have
encountered in math or even in the real world,
even if you haven't sort of applied this name to it.
Recursion
is a technique in mathematics and in programming that allows you to take
sort of a fundamentally different approach to a problem and in short,
a recursive function is one that's defined in terms of itself.
So if you had like F of X equals F of
something on the right hand side of a mathematical expression,
that would be recursive in that
the function is dependent on itself.
More practically in the world of programming,
a recursive function is a function that calls it.
Self.
So if you are writing some function in C
and in that function you call yourself.
You actually have a line of code that says call that same function by the same name,
that function is recursive.
Now
this might feel a little weird because if a function is calling itself,
it feels like this is the easiest way to get into an infinite
loop because why would it ever stop if the function is calling itself,
calling itself,
calling itself?
We're going to have to actually address that kind of problem.
But in the real world.
We've actually,
or rather in this class already,
we've actually seen implicitly an example of this,
including today as well as in week 0.
So here's that algorithm for searching
the doors of the lockers and recall that after we did this
check at the very top if there are any doors left,
returned false,
if not,
we did these
conditions.
We said if the numbers behind the middle door returned true because we found it,
but things got interesting here.
I said if else if the number is less than the middle door,
then search the left half.
Else if the number is greater than the middle door,
then search the right half.
Well,
at that point in time,
you should be asking me or yourself,
well,
how do I search the left half?
How do I search the right half?
Well,
here you go.
Like on the screen right now is a search algorithm,
and even though it says down here search the left half or search the right half,
which is like,
well,
how do I do?
That we'll just use the same algorithm again
and this is how in terms of my voiceover you end up searching the left half
of the left half or the right half of the left half or any such combination.
This line here search left half,
this line here search right half is representative of
a recursive call.
This is an algorithm or a function that calls itself,
but why does it not induce an infinite loop?
Like why is it important that this line and this line are written exactly as they are,
so as to avoid this thing just forever searching
aimlessly,
yeah.
We do have this condition at which it stops,
but more importantly,
what is happening before I make these recursive calls?
Exactly,
I'm recursing,
that is calling myself,
but I'm handing myself a smaller problem,
a smaller problem,
a smaller problem.
It would be bad if I just handed myself the exact
same number of doors and just kept saying search these,
search these,
search these because you would never make any progress.
But
just like our volunteers earlier,
so long as we did divide and conquer and
we searched smaller and smaller numbers of doors,
eventually indeed we're going to bottom out and
either find the number we're looking for or
we're not.
So.
we're going to call these kinds of conditions that sort of
just ask a very obvious question and want an immediate answer
base cases.
Base cases are generally conditionals that ask a question to which the
answer is going to be yes or no right then and there.
A recursive case,
by contrast,
these two down here is when you actually need to do
a bit more work to get to your final answer.
You call yourself,
but with a smaller version of the problem.
So we could have in fact in week 0 have written this.
Sort of similarly,
if you go back to in your mind to week 0,
we had more of a procedural approach,
so to speak.
When we were searching the phone book,
I proposed that this induced what we called loops on line 8 and line 11,
which is literally said go back to line 3,
and that was more of a mechanical way of sort of inducing a loop structure.
But if I really wanted to be elegant,
I could have
said,
well,
you know what,
7 and 8 together really just means search the left half and
10 and 11 together really mean just search the right half.
So let's condense these.
Pairs of lines into shorter instructions.
Search the left half of the book,
search the right half of the book.
I can then delete two blank lines,
and now I have a recursive algorithm for searching a phone book.
It's a little less obvious because you have to ask yourself when you get to line 7 or 9,
Wait a minute,
how do I search the left half or the right half?
And that's when you need to realize
you start the same algorithm again but with a problem that's half as large.
In week 0 we do the procedural approach where we
literally tell you what line of code to go to.
But today
we're offering a different formulation,
a recursive approach where it's more implicit what you should do.
And we'll see now a couple of examples from the real world,
so to speak.
So here's a screenshot from Super Mario Brothers
1 on the original Nintendo Entertainment System.
Let me go ahead and get rid of some of the distraction,
like the ground and the mountains there,
and here we have a sort of half pyramid,
not unlike that you implemented in Problems set 1,
but this is an interesting real world physical structure
in that you can define it recursively,
like what is a pyramid of height.
4,
if you will.
Well,
just to be a little,
a little difficult,
a pyramid of height 4 is really just a pyramid of height 3
plus one more row.
OK,
well,
what is a pyramid of height 3?
Well,
a pyramid of height 3 is really just a pyramid of height 2 plus one more row.
what's a pyramid of height 2?
Well,
a pyramid of height 2 is really just a pyramid of height 1 plus one more row.
what's a pyramid of height 1?
A single brick on the screen.
And I sort of changed my tone with that last remark to convey
that this could then be our base case whereby I just tell you
what the thing is without sort of kicking the can and inviting you
to think through what a smaller structure is plus one more row,
whereas every other
definition I gave you then of a pyramid of some height
was defined in terms of
that same structure,
albeit a smaller version thereof.
So we can actually
see this in the real world.
Let me go ahead and pull up one thing here.
I'm going to go to.
Give me one sec before I flip over.
Here I am on Google.com,
if you'd like a little computer science humor here.
Uh,
if you ever Google search for recursion and hit enter,
you'll see
uh a joke that
computer scientists at Google find funny.
Ha ha,
12,
lasts.
Does anyone see the joke?
I did not make a typo,
but Google's asking me,
did I mean recursion?
And if I click on that,
I just get the same ha ha page.
OK,
all right,
that didn't go over well.
Anyhow,
so
there are these Easter eggs in the wild everywhere because
computer scientists are the ones that implement these things.
But let's go ahead and actually
implement,
for instance,
a version of this in code.
Let me go back over here in a moment to VS code,
and in VS Code,
let me propose that in my terminal window.
Let me create one of two final programs.
This one's.
Going to be called iteration.c just to make
clear that this is the iterative that is loop-based
version of a program whose purpose in life is to print out a simple Mario pyramid.
I'm going to go ahead and include CS50.
H at the top as well as standardio.h.
I'm not going to need string.h.
I don't need any command line arguments today,
so this is going to start off with main void.
And now I'm going to go ahead and ask a question like,
uh,
give me a variable called height of type integer
and ask the human for the height of this Mario like pyramid.
And then let's assume for the moment
that I've already implemented a function called
Draw whose purpose in life is to draw a pyramid of that height semicolon.
So I've abstracted away for the moment the notion of drawing that pyramid.
Now let's actually implement Dra,
whose purpose in life again is to print out a pyramid akin to
the one we saw a moment ago like this here on the screen.
Well,
in order to print out a pyramid of a given height,
I think I need to say void.
Uh,
drawn for instance because I'm not going to bother returning a value.
I just want this thing to print something on the screen,
so void is the return type,
but I do want to take as input an integer like the height of the thing I want to print.
I can call this argument or parameter anything I want.
I'll call it N for number.
So how can I print out a pyramid that again looks like this?
Well,
I'll do this quicker than you might have in problem set 1,
but it seems obvious that like on the first row I want 1 brick.
On the second row I want 2.
On the 3rd I want 3.
On the 4th,
I want 4.
So it's actually a little easier than problem set
1 in that it's sloped in a different direction.
So let me go ahead and do exactly this in code.
Let me say 4
NI equals 01 less than n,
the height,
I plus plus.
So this is going to be really
for each row of the pyramid
pyramid.
Let me go ahead now
and in an inner loop for in J equals 0,
let's do J less than.
I plus 1 for reasons we'll see in a moment and then J++ and then inside of this loop,
let's just print out a single hash,
no new line,
but at the end of the row,
let's print out a single new line to move the cursor to the next line.
Now why am I doing this?
Well,
this represents
for each column of
pyramid,
and if you think about it on the first row,
which is row 0,
I actually want to print not zero bricks but one brick.
That's why I want to go ahead here and go from 0 to I plus 1,
because if I is +01 + 1 is 1,
so my inner loop is going to go from 0 to 1,
which is going to give me 1 brick.
It's a little annoying to think about the math,
but this just makes sure that I'm actually getting bricks in the order I want them.
And then it's going to give me 2 bricks and then 3 and then 4,
and between each of those rows it's going to print a new line.
So let's go ahead and do make iteration to compile this code.
Ah,
I messed up.
Why do I have a mistake online?
8 of this code.
Let me hide my terminal and scroll back up.
It seems clang.
My compiler does not like my draw function.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I forgot the prototype.
So this is the one and only time where it seems reasonable to copy paste.
Let's grab the prototype of that function up here
and go ahead and teach the compiler from the
get-go what this function is going to look like,
even though I'm not defining it now until line 13 onward.
All right,
let's go ahead and make iteration again.
Ah,
iteration enter.
Let's do a height of say 4 and voila.
Now I've got that there pyramid.
So I did it a little quickly and it's certainly to be expected if it
took you hours on problems set one to get the other type of pyramid printed,
but the point for today is really to demonstrate how we can
print a pyramid like this using indeed what I'd call iteration.
Iteration just means using loops to solve some problem,
but we can.
Alternatively use recursion by reimplementing our draw function in
a way that's defined in terms of itself.
So let me go into my code here
and I'm actually going to leave the prototype the same.
I'm going to leave main the same,
but what I'm going to go ahead and do is delete
all of this iterative code that's doing things very procedurally,
step by step by step with loops,
and I'm instead going to do something
like this.
Well,
if I want to print a pyramid of height N.
What did I say earlier?
Well,
a pyramid of height N is really just a pyramid of height N minus 1 plus 1 more row.
So how do I implement in code that idea?
Well,
let me go back in code here and say,
well,
if a pyramid of height N first requires drawing a pyramid of height N minus 1,
I think I can just write this,
which is kind of crazy to look at,
but
because you're calling yourself in yourself,
but let's see where this takes us.
Once I have drawn a pyramid of height and minus 1.
That is a height 3 for instance.
What remains for me to do is to myself print one more row.
And so to print one more row,
I think I can do that really easily with fewer loops.
I can do 4 in,
I equals 01 less than N I plus plus,
and then very simply in this loop I can.
Print out a single hash one at a time.
At the end of this loop,
I can print out a new line,
but no more nesting of loops.
What I've done is
print one more row,
and here
I've done print
a pyramid of height and minus 1.
I'm not quite done yet,
but I think this is consistent with my verbal definition that a pyramid of height 3
is a pyramid of a pyramid of height 4 is a pyramid of height 3,
which I can implement
per line 16.
Just draw me a pyramid of height and minus 1,
and then I myself will take the trouble to print the 4th and final row.
But something's missing in this code.
Let me go ahead and try running it.
Let's see what happens.
Make,
oh darn it.
I meant to call this something else,
so I'm going to do this.
I'm going to close this version here.
I'm going to rename iteration.c to recursion.c to
make clear that this version is completely different.
Let me now go ahead and make the recursion version
and huh,
Klang is noticing that I have screwed up on line 14,
it says error.
All paths through this function will call itself,
and Klang doesn't even want to let me
compile this code because that would mean literally
just forever.
Loop
effectively by calling yourself.
So what am I missing in my code here if I open up what we're now calling recursion.c.
In my editor
What's missing here over here?
Yeah,
I'm missing a base case,
and I can express this in a few different ways,
but I would propose that before I do any drawing of anything at all,
let's just ask ourselves if there is anything to draw.
So how about if N equals equals 0?
Well then don't do anything,
just return.
You don't return a value when your return value is void,
it means you don't return anything,
so you just return period or return semicolon.
Or just to be super safe,
I could actually do something like this,
which is arguably better practice just in case I get into
this perverse scenario where someone hands me a negative number,
I want to be able to handle that and not print anything either.
So just to be safe,
I might say less than or equal to 0.
I'm not doing one
because if I did do one,
then I would want to at least myself print out one brick,
which is fine,
but I have to like
change all of my code.
Little bit,
so I think it's safer if my base case is just
if n
is less than or equal to 0,
you're done.
Don't do anything.
And this then ensures that even though thereafter,
I keep calling draw again and again and again and the problem's
getting smaller and smaller from 4 to 3 to 2 to 1,
as soon as I hit 0,
the function will finally
return.
So let's go ahead and open up my terminal,
rerun make recursion to make this version did compile this time recursion enter.
Let's type in 4 cross my fingers,
and this too prints the exact same thing.
And even though it doesn't look like fewer lines of code,
I would offer that there's an elegance to what I've just done,
whereas with the iterative version with all the loops,
it was very clunky,
like step by step,
just print this and print that and have a nested loop inside of another.
But with this,
especially if we distill it into its essence.
By getting rid of my comments like this and
frankly I can get rid of the unnecessary curly braces
only because for single lines in conditionals you don't need them.
Like this is arguably like a
very beautiful implementation of drawing Mario's pyramid
even though it's calling itself and arguably because it is calling
itself.
Questions then on this idea of recursion or this implementation
of Mario,
yeah.
Call
Good question.
Are there any scope issues involved?
Short answer No.
However,
the current value of I,
for instance,
will not be visible
to the next time the function is called.
It will have its own copy of I
if that's what you mean.
And we'll next week talk in more detail about what's going on here.
And in fact,
I probably can't break this in class very easily,
but
it turns out if I use a very large version for heights,
let's just hit a lot of zeros and see what happens.
That was too many.
Let's see what happens.
That's also too many.
Let's see what happens
there.
That's the first time at least I and class have encountered this error.
You might have encountered this weird bug in office hours or in your problem set,
and that's fine if you did.
We'll talk about what this means next week too,
but this is bad.
Like this clearly hints at a problem in my code.
However,
the iterative version of this program would not have that same error.
So this relates to something involving memory because it
turns out as a little teaser for next week.
Each time I call Draw,
I'm using a little more memory,
a little more memory,
and my computer only has so much memory.
This program in its current form is using too much memory.
There are workarounds to this,
but that is a trade off to the elegance we're gaining in this solution.
So what's the point of all this and how do we get sidetracked by Mario?
There's another sorting algorithm,
the 3rd and final one that we'll consider today that actually Is recursion
to solve the problem not only elegantly
arguably,
but also way faster somehow
than bubble sort and selection sort.
And in essence it does so by making far fewer comparisons and wasting a lot less work.
It doesn't keep comparing the same numbers again and again.
Here in its essence is the pseudo code for merge sort.
Sort the left half of the numbers.
So the right half of the numbers,
then merge the sorted halves,
and this is kind of a weird implementation of
an algorithm because I'm not really telling you anything.
It seems like you're asking me how do I sort numbers,
and I say,
we'll sort the left half,
sort the right half.
It's like someone being difficult
and yet implicit in this third line is apparently some magic,
this notion of merging halves that are somehow already.
is actually going to yield a successful result.
As an aside,
we're actually going to need one base case here too.
So if you're only given one number,
you might as well quit right away because there's nothing to do.
So we'll toss that in there as well.
And base cases are often for 0 or 1 or some small num sized problem.
In this case it's a little easier to express it as one because if you have one element,
it's indeed already sorted.
So what does it mean to merge two sorted halves?
Well,
let's actually consider this.
I'm going to reuse some of these same numbers here.
I'm going to put my 1,
my 3,
my 4,
and my 6 on the left,
and these together represent a list that is indeed
sorted of size 4.
And then I'm going to put 4 other numbers
on the right there that are similarly sorted.
As well,
and by merging these two lists,
I mean
start at the left end of this list,
and just decide one step at a time which number is the next smallest,
and then I'm going to put it on the top shelf to make clear what is sorted.
So if my left hand's pointing at this list,
my right hand's pointing at there,
which hand is obviously pointing to the smaller element,
left or right.
Like the right,
so I'm going to grab this and I'm going to use a little more space up top here
and put the 0 in place and then I'm going to point to the next element there.
So my left hand has not moved yet.
It's still pointing at the 1.
My right hand is pointing at the 2,
which number comes next clearly?
Left,
so I'm going to grab the 1 and put it up there and update where my left hand is pointing.
So now I'm pointing at the 3 here and the 2 there.
What comes next?
Obviously the 2.
Obviously the 3.
What comes next,
obviously the 4.
obviously the 5,
but notice my hands are not going back and forth,
back and forth,
back and forth like any of the algorithms thus far.
I'm just taking baby steps,
moving them only to the right,
effectively pointing at for a final time each number once and only once.
What comes next,
6,
and now my left hand is done.
What comes last,
the number 7.
What I just did is what I mean by
merge the sorted halves.
If you can somehow get into a scenario where you've
got a small list sorted and another small list sorted,
it's super easy now to merge them together using that left right approach,
which I'll claim only takes end steps.
Why?
Because every time I asked you a question,
I was taking one.
Out of the problem,
there's 8 bytes total.
I asked you 8 questions or I would have if I verbalized them all.
So it's N steps total to merge lists of that size.
So
what then is merge sort?
Mergesort is really all three of these steps together,
only one of which we've acted out,
2 of which are sort of cyclical in nature.
They're recursive by design.
So what does this mean?
Well,
let's start with this list of eight numbers,
which is clearly out of order 63,
4152,
70 and let's apply
mergesor to this set of numbers and I'll do it digitally here because
it'll take forever to keep moving the numbers up and down physically.
So let's move it to the top just to give ourselves a little bit more room
and let me propose that we apply mergesort.
What was the very first step in mergesort,
at least that we highlighted,
the juicy steps.
What's the first step in mergesor?
Sort the left half,
yeah.
And then the second step was going to be sort the right half
and then the third step was going to be merge the sorted halves.
So let's see what this means by actually acting it out on these numbers.
So here's my 8 numbers.
Let's go ahead and sort the left half.
Well,
the left half is obviously going to be the 4 numbers on the left,
and I'm just going to pull them out just to draw our attention to them over here.
Now I have a list of size 4,
and the goal is to sort the left half.
How do I sort a list of size 4?
Uh,
be what was yes,
but just be more pedantic.
Like how do I sort any list using merge sort?
Sort the left half.
So let's do just that.
So of the list of size 4,
how do I sort this?
Well,
I'm going to sort the left half.
How do I sort a list of size 2?
Sort the left half,
right,
well,
I'm just gonna write the 6 here.
How do I sort a list of size 1?
I just don't.
I'm done.
That was the so-called base case where I just said return,
like I'm done sorting the list.
OK,
so
here I here's the story recap.
So the left half,
sort the left half,
and I just finished sorting this.
So what comes next?
Sort the right half,
which is this,
and now I've sorted the left half of
the left half of the left half,
which is a big mouthful,
but what do I do as a third and final step when sorting this list of size 2.
Merge them.
This part we know how to do.
I point left and right,
and I now take the smallest element first,
which is the 3.
Then I take the 6 and now this list of size 2 is sorted.
So if you remind in your mind's eye what step are we on,
well,
we have now sorted
the left half of the left half.
So what comes after
the left half is sorted?
We sort the right half.
So we're sort of rewinding in time,
but that's OK.
I'm keeping track of the steps in my mind.
I want to now
sort this list of size 2.
How do you sort a list of size 2?
Well,
you divide it into a list of size 1.
How do you sort this?
You're done.
You then take the other right half and you sort it.
Done.
Now you merge the two sorted halves.
So I point at the 4 and the 1,
obviously the one comes first,
then the 4.
Now I have sorted the right half of the uh the right half
of the left half of the original numbers.
What's the next step now that I have the left and right halves of this list of 4 sorted?
Merge those,
so same idea but fewer elements.
I'm pointing at the 3 and the 1.
Obviously the 1 comes now I'm pointing at the 3 and the 4.
Obviously the 3 comes next,
pointing at the 6 and the 4,
the 4 comes next,
and now the 6 comes last.
Now I have sorted the left half and it's intentional that 1346 is the
original arrangement of the lighted numbers I had on the shelves a moment ago.
All right,
it's a long story it seems,
but what comes after you sorting the left half of the original list?
You sort the right half.
So let's put some,
uh,
put those numbers over here.
How do I sort a list of size 4?
Well,
you sort the left half.
How do you sort this thing of size 2?
You sort the left half,
you sort the right half,
and now you merge
those together.
How do I now sort the right half of the right half?
Well,
I sort the left half,
I sort the right half,
and then I merge those together.
Now,
I have sorted the left half and the right half
of the right half of the original elements.
What's next?
The merging,
025.
And 7.
Now we're exactly where we were originally with the lighted numbers.
I've got 1346,
the left half sorted,
02 57.
The right half sorted.
What's the third and final step?
Merge those two halves,
of course,
0123456.
And 7
And hopefully even though there's a lot of words that
come out of my mouth as acting this out,
there wasn't a lot of back and forth.
Like I definitely wasn't like walking back and forth physically and
I also wasn't comparing the same numbers again and again.
I was doing sort of different work at different conceptual levels,
but that was like only what,
like 3 levels total.
It wasn't N
levels on the board visually.
So where does this get us with merge sort?
Well,
with mergesort,
it would seem that
we have an algorithm that I claim is doing a lot less work.
The catch.
Is that merge sort requires twice as much space just as we saw
when I needed two shelves in order to merge those two lists.
So how much less work is actually going to be possible?
Well,
let's consider sort of the analysis of the original list and how we
might describe its its running time in terms of this big O notation.
Hopefully it's not going to be as bad as n2d ultimately.
So here are some like bread crumbs that if I hadn't kept
updating the screen and deleting numbers once we move them around,
here's sort of like traces of every.
Bit of work that we did,
we started up here,
we did the left half,
the left half of the left half,
the right half of the right half,
and then everything else in between,
and you'll see that essentially I took a list of size 8 and I did
3 different passes through it at this conceptual level,
at this conceptual level,
and at this one.
And each time I did that I had to merge elements
together and if you kind of think about it here,
I pointed at 4 elements here and 4 elements here and in total I pointed at 8 elements.
So there was end steps here for merging
and if you.
Trust me,
I'll claim that on this level conceptually there were also 8 steps.
I wasn't merging lists of size 4,
but I was merging 2 lists of size 2 over here and 2 more lists of size 2 over there.
So if you add those up,
those are in total steps or or merges if you will.
And then down here this was kind of silly.
I was,
but I was merging ultimately 8 single lists altogether
into the higher level of
of conceptually.
So from a list of size 8 we sort of had 3 levels of work.
And on each level we did n steps,
the merging.
So whereas 3?
Well,
it turns out if you have 8 elements up here,
the relationship between 8 and 3 is actually something formulaic,
and we can describe it as log base 2 of n.
Why?
Because if n is 8,
if you don't mind doing some logarithms here,
logba 2 of 8 is the same thing as logbase 2 of 23 power.
The log 2 and the 2 cancel itself out,
which gives you exactly the number 3.
That I sort of
visualized with those traces on the screen,
which is to say,
irrespective of the specific value of N,
the big O running time of merge sort is apparently not n squared,
but it's log n
times n or more conventionally n times log n.
Because you're doing things,
log n times technically based 2,
but we don't care about that generally for big O notation.
And indeed in big O notation we would say that
merge sort is on the order of N log N.
That's its big O running time sort of at the upper bound.
What about the lower order bound?
Well,
there's no clever optimization in our current
implementation as there was for bubble sort,
and so it turns out
the lower bound would be in omega of N log N
and in theta,
therefore,
Of and log in as well because Big O and Omega are in fact in this case one and the same.
And if we actually go back to our visualization from earlier,
give me just a moment to pull that up here in
our earlier implementation or an earlier demonstration of these algorithms,
we had
a side by side comparison of all of the comparisons,
but here if I go ahead and randomize it and click Merge sort,
you'll see a very different and clearly faster algorithm,
even though the computer speed has not changed.
But it's touching these elements so many fewer times it's wasting a lot less time
because of this cleverness where it's instead dividing and conquering
the problem into smaller and smaller and smaller pieces.
And to give this a final flourish,
since that was,
yes,
faster,
but not necessarily obviously faster than other things that we've done,
how might we actually compare these things side by side by side?
Well,
in our final moments together,
let's go ahead and.
Amatically and for no real reason,
just dim the lights so that I'll hit play on a visualization that at the
top is going to show you selection sort with a bunch of random data.
On the bottom it's going to show you show you bubble sort with a bunch of random data
and in the middle is going to show you merge sort and the takeaway
ultimately for today is the appreciable feel of difference between big O of N2d
and now the big O of N log N.
All right,
the music just makes sorting more fun,
but that's it for today.
We will see you next time.